[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled utilization of the
luminex platform to discover and develop
dual toll-like receptor two and nine
antigenous for the treatment of
neurodegenerative diseases this webinar
is part of the 10th annual neuroscience
virtual conference
i'm antonina salcido of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
luminix a diasoren company for more
information about lunix please go to
luminexcorp.com
now let's get started
before we begin i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to first participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation
you can find that live chat located at
the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you would like
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credits click on
the continuing education credits link
located in your abstract window below
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
i now present today's speaker dr diana l
price executive director of biosciences
at neuropor therapies inc
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen
dr price you may now begin your
presentation thank you and thank you for
that introduction
before i get started today i want to
thank members of the lemonex corporation
team for the invitation for sponsoring
and to labyrinths for organizing this
event uh program data i will be
presenting today represents the combined
efforts of past and current members of
neuropore's drug discovery and
development team
the program was jump started by a grant
from michael j fox to build an in vitro
screening platform
followed by add-on funding to evaluate a
promising program lead in an aviva model
of parkinson's disease
and we've now leveraged on the developed
in vitro and aviva platforms to extend
our evaluations to additional models of
nerd of neurodegeneration
now neuropoor is a pretty small company
and so in order to facilitate our
efforts on this program and other
programs we have leveraged upon a
preferred network of collaborations with
industry and academic partners and we
i've shown a small number of those here
so
the development of cns disease modifying
therapeutics from concept to approval
takes a great deal of time effort and
money
over 85 percent of combined phase 2 and
3 cns targeted therapeutics fail
and this includes both symptomatic and
disease modifying therapeutics
and i say that because
of
the
approvals in cnf very very few
have been disease modifying therapeutics
and those are therapeutics that either
slow
stop or reverse the progression of a
disease
so there have been some notable
exceptions
primarily in
multiple sclerosis als and more recently
for alzheimer's disease
so
how can we improve our success rate what
can we do to improve the pre-clinical to
clinical translation
and i'd like to briefly focus on two key
translational challenges to developing
disease modifying therapeutics for
neurodegenerative diseases
centered on the patient population and
biomarkers
so
first key
pop first key challenge being the
centered around the patient population
where variability in clinical trial data
can be largely explained
by patient population related factors
first there are knowledge gaps in the
understandings of all these disorders
with regards to mechanism and there are
usually more than one
progression of these underlying
mechanisms
and optimal points for intervention
and heterogeneity within clinical
cohorts contribute to variability and
ultimately to trial failure
including
time
if you think of a patient population
you've got all these patients within
your trial and they have different times
from a symptom onset time from diagnos
from diagnosis
the rate of progression their symptom
profiles and and sometimes they even
have uh within the population you have
patients who are considered
non-responders to your therapeutic
intervention so it would be great to
know who they are before you start your
clinical trial
on the right i have shown a i'm showing
a schematic
which is related to parkinson's disease
with time-dependent progressions of
pathology overlaid with progressive
symptoms
so briefly walking through the layered
aspects from top to bottom
and this is just a small part of the
complexity of parkinson's disease
first of all they're progress
progressive accumulations of a protein
called alpha synuclein in the brain
and it turns out in the periphery as
well
and these this progressive pathology is
associated with progressive changes in
neurochemistry
neuronal cell death
autonomic dysfunction neuropsychiatric
features and motor dysfunction
and all of our our understanding of all
of the above is complicated by
additional complex and dynamic changes
in autophagy
and immune pathways elements of those
pathways and the function of those
pathways
as well as changes in network
connectivity and dysfunction
and changes in cellular metabolism
now the challenges related to the
patient population are related to the
second clinical development challenge of
biomarker discovery development and use
now there are different types of
biomarkers including
diagnostic
patient stratification
target engagement disease progression
and therapeutic response
now along the bottom of the slide are
some examples parkinson's disease
imaging functional and
biomarkers
now some of these biomarkers are
potentially multi-purpose but most are
not
for example
the dopamine transporter pet imaging
is used as a parkinson's disease
diagnostic
test
however it is
likely not useful as a therapeutic
response biomarker
a successful trial in parkinson's or
other
will likely
require multiple biomarkers
for example
a positive that stand could be an
inclusion criteria biomarker
for patient stratification
with additional biomarkers for clinical
symptoms such as the rating scale for
parkinson's disease updrs
and target engagement biomarkers that
are specific for your therapeutic
intervention
so one emerging strategy is to utilize a
combination of biomarkers and look for
consistent patterns of multiple
endpoints in early clinical trials
and using this approach various
biomarkers can be critically evaluated
for sensitivity selectivity and
robustness
and
inform your clinical development program
so neuropore therapies develop small
molecule therapeutics that target common
mechanisms which drive neurodegeneration
on the left is a schematic showing three
key pathologies common to most
neurodegenerative diseases
of protein pathology
increased inflammation and deficits and
clearance mechanisms which
collectively we call autophagy
now many neurodegenerative disorders are
associated with one or more abnormal
aggregated proteins
they have markers for increased
inflammation and there are different
types of autophagy that we have evidence
for changes in and dysregulation
so neuropore therapies is pursuing three
distinct therapeutic approaches based on
this triad to develop therapeutics for
slime progression of neurodegenerative
diseases by
either directly
interacting with with toxic proteins
by inhibiting brain inflammatory
processes involved in the disease or by
rectifying deficits in cellular
mechanisms
for clearing aggregates or misfolded
proteins
are i'm uh i've led ambivo pharmacology
efforts at uh neuropor therapies along
with uh translational science aspects of
the programs
and um we
the three key aspects of our vivo
pharmacology program
are shown here
the first is a general approach
and utilize technologies
we've chosen to invest in and use
technologies that can be used regardless
of discovery program or indication so
their program and indication agnostic
we are a very small company with
comparatively fewer resources space and
time compared to larger companies and so
we have necessarily built a multimodal
and multiplexed unbiased toolkit of
study measures that are flexible
efficient and support all of our
programs and here are some examples
underneath of some types of those data
evaluations biochemistry gene expression
behavior neuropathology layered with
different types of imaging analysis
the second key aspect of the platinum
form are the ambivo animal models that
we use
that
include wild type animals for
pharmakinetic and target engagement
studies
we conduct in-house evaluations of
transgenic models of parkinson's disease
and als
and we access additional models through
collaborations and partnerships
again these are used for evaluations of
target engagement model characterization
you know is this a model that we think
would be useful for our program
uh in vivo target validation
chronic studies for proof of concept
for pre-clinical pre-clinical proof of
concept and biomarker develop early
biomarker development
and finally in addition to our
cross-functional interactions with our
neuropro colleagues in chemistry and
individual in vitro pharmacology
the imbibo group uses chem the aviva
group uses collaborations
and cro partnerships where we manage
outsource admin pk and
efficacy studies with industry and
academic partners we utilize a ciro
vivarium and again we use specialized
providers like redoxes to access
models
it's just a much more efficient way to
conduct our
first
approximation studies
so how are we using luminix platform
we're using it in biochemical and gene
expression measurements using singleplex
and or multiplex kits to develop and
validate amiibo models
to use them for in vivo target
engagement profiling
for characterization of preclinical
mouse models
for efficacy evaluations and preclinical
mouse models looking for any um
signal of benefit in those models
and for early translational biomarker
methods and when what i mean by
translation in the context of drugs or
drug discovery efforts
we look for translation uh from in vitro
to in vivo
and as close as we can to human
and and back and forth so an iterative
process process so that we can learn and
adjust
so now i'm going to shift gears
to describe the program that we're very
excited about our tlr program
now toll-like receptors are host pattern
recognition receptors positioned to play
a role both in the innate and adaptive
immune responses and their activation
triggers cellular inflammatory responses
to molecular patterns
now i'm going to refer to them as tlrs
tlrs are localized to cell surfaces and
intracellularly they can be triggered by
pattern-associated molecular patterns
which we refer to as pamps
and or
damage-associated molecular patterns
damps with
mighty 88 dependent and independent
signaling leading to inflammatory
signaling
now pamps could be thought of as
non-self such as viruses and bacteria
and damps can be thought of as self
in infectious diseases
tlr activation initiates an immune
response that results in elimination of
pathogens and that's usually followed by
resolution of an inflammatory state
in neurogeneration however
this we have
evidence that the activation of these
receptors exacerbates exacerbates
neuronal damage
and further release of damps
promoting a persistent inflammatory
state without resolution so this is a
chronic and maladaptive state
now the program was initially focused on
the hypothesis that aberrant tlr2
activation in glial cells and or neurons
plays key roles in the processes
underlying neurodegenerative
degeneration primarily parkinson's
disease was our initial focus
where we know that tlr2 is upregulated
in patient samples
from parkinson's disease patients as
well as other nerve degenerative
disorders and this correlates with
misfolded protein burden
if
you activate tlr2 in animal models you
increase misfolded protein and
pathog and pathology and if you block
this in vitro you can basically
you can ameliorate this
so it's that we have evidence that tlr
to down regulation reduces protein
pathology and blocks neurodegeneration
so our thought process is that
our application of antagonists
as a therapeutic intervention may
provide benefit by two complementary
mechanisms by blocking chronic
activation of glia
to reduce neurotoxic inflammation
or
and or by reducing the
block of protein clearance mechanisms in
neurons resulting in reduced protein
aggregation as you restore their
clearance
mechanisms
now neuroporos tlr2 program in vitro pro
platform was built to guide compound
selection for advancement
the in vitro platform development and
early screening was supported by the
michael j fox foundation
and the in vitro team employed multiple
cellular systems as shown and readouts
for compound screening and
characterization
they cut
they
set very clear decision driving criteria
and uh multiple strategies uh targeting
the extracellular intercellular sites of
the tlr-2 receptor
were were targeted
and this platform was used to evaluate
over 62 000 compounds
and from this campaign
several novel and nanomolar potent and
selective receptor antagonists were
identified
so here i'm showing you our screening
tiers so that's basically our strategy
of how we're going to pro how we're
going to prosecute
the
evaluation
in the drug discovery process of our
compounds and so on the left you have
very clear
go and no go drivers for our decision
making process
with regard to in vitro and in vivo
evaluations
and by design
the screening tier is indication
agnostic
basically we use the criteria in the
left to learn about our compound and
what it does in vitro and in vivo and
then based on our findings we decide to
conduct another set of informing
endpoint studies
that may be more tailored towards
specific indications and so this allows
us to be opportunistic in terms of
explorations of indications
so screening
in recombinant tailor to hex cells
identified a compound designated as npt
1220-312
and i'll refer to that um
interchangeably
as that or 312.
so this compound exhibited sub nanomolar
potency
with minimal cellular toxicity and
outsourced admin pk evaluations didn't
reveal any issues with the compound
um so that's um
uh
and then shifting a little bit in terms
of our informing endpoints
we found
we being the uh in vitro group found
that our compound blocked tlr2 signaling
and cytokine release of
a particular cytokine il8
in peripheral immune and central immune
cells it blocked nlrp
inflammasome markers in differentiated
human macrophages and it blocks
biologically relevant activators of tlr2
signaling
such as p acnes and p gingivalis
so in parallel the aviva pharmacology
group was exploring multiple options for
in vivo target engagement
and what i'm showing here is
is based on a developed and validated
acute peripheral tlr2 agonist evoked
model
that's conducted in wild-type mice
and we use the pam-2 agonist pam-3
to
evoke a
a
cytokine response
and we've validated that
which of those analytes are sensitive to
tlr2
inhibition
so using a 32-plex plasma kit a 32-plex
mouse kit in our samples
we evaluated the evoked plasma profile
using the luminex platform and i'm
showing here
on the upper panel and lower panels the
cytokine concentration response curves
so we also have the
compound uh exposures from plasma
and so the upper graphs show data for
the two mouth two of three mouse
homologues for il-8 so if you recall
that's the analyte that the in vitro
group evaluated
um demonstrating that we
have a dose response
concentration response curves here um of
our compound versus a tlr2 activation
and on the bottom
i'm showing two highlights of analytes
that
show uh
il-6 and mip-1 beta that are relevant to
neurodegeneration um if you look at the
literature of this pop up pretty
frequently um but if you look across all
of the analytes um the overall response
profile
demonstrates an animal or potency of
about 550 nanomolar of our compound
across
a broad panel of analytes as
measured here
and again this is in wild type mice
so um
you know i've talked about the overall
response profile
and you know that they're
i'm showing here basically some
exploratory pca modeling as one way to
visualize um this change uh this
normalization of the profile
and so on the left uh the largest circle
is
basically the non-evoked state so you
have
the animal gets a vehicle pre-treatment
they get a
vehicle
treatment and that's basically the
boundary of of their
response profile that's the larger on
the left
on the right is the tlr2 agonist evoked
profile so you see it's shifted to the
right
now
um this uh profile if you look across
phantom lights it's it's robust it's
complex
you know i've referred to these as
cytokines but it's a mixture of
cytokines chemokines and different
growth factors
so we're getting a pretty reliable and
robust
tlr2 agonist evoked profile
and our treatment with tlr2
antibodies or our compound normalized
this response shifted back left towards
the vehicle vehicle group profile
so this is just a visualization of how
useful it can be to to look at
multiple analytes rather than just
focusing on those that
you go into
based on the literature
so in the background the vitro
pharmacology group added additional
taylor
subtype evaluations because we needed to
know how specific this was to tlr2
and they determined that our molecules
actually have similar potency at tlr and
tlr9 tlr2 and tlr9 receptors
um again going through the list they
block both
tlr2 and tlr9 activation of peripheral
and central immune cells they block
synthetic and natural tlr activators
and they block nlrp inflammasome markers
in differentiated human macrophages
and uh like tlr2 there's uh evidence for
tlr9 involvement and multiple
neurodegenerative diseases taylor knight
is an intracellular
toll like receptor
and the
tlr9 activation releases mitochondrial
dna that leads to immune cell activation
including activation of microglia in the
cns
so from the perspective of the link to
inflammation and microglia you could see
how this would be possibly relevant
so
using the limix platform uh we've
conducted multiplex evaluations of
plasma cytokines again
in the top panel we have the tlr the e
in vivo tlr2 engagement data um some of
that for uh the mouse isolate homologs
um
with our one of our newer program
molecules um and so basically that's
tracked very well with our early
findings with um
other program molecules
and
in the bottom panels
we these are related to our development
of a tlr9 target engagement in vivo
target engagement model for program
molecule evaluations
again demonstrating that
we could block
tlr9
agonist evoked cytokines and a cytokine
profile if we pretreat with our compound
so uh overall the multiplex evaluations
of plasma cytokines have really enabled
um us to
make unbiased comparisons of the
response profiles of our program
molecules um and again that's something
kind of important as we move into the
space of trying to decide
how we want to evaluate these with
respect to different models of
indications
so
with that in mind
you know we
our
expertise
really lies in parkinson's disease
but we took a step back and decided to
do an indication
we we conducted an indication exercise
we evaluated over 60 cns and non-cns
indications
sort of to give us a feel for what the
the potential of this program might be
all of the indications have a pathogenic
inflammatory component
plus evidence for involvement of tlr2
and or tlr9 as
as derived from studies of patients
or pre-clinical models
there are many opportunities here as you
can see
not just in the cns space to diversify
applications in large or rare patient
populations with unmet need which is a
key criteria for us internally
and importantly tlr9 and tl tlr2
inhibitors have advanced through phase
one clinical safety evaluations without
any issues today
so ultimately
though we you know being the small
company we had to focus a bit and so we
decided on three key indications for our
informing endpoint studies
parkinson's disease als and
guillain-barre syndrome
so very briefly
some of you may be familiar or likely
familiar with parkinson's disease
again it's a it's a disease that has a
protein pathology
alpha synuclein protein pathology is a
hallmark of parkinson's disease
neurodegeneration and neurotransmitter
changes uh lead to network dysfunction
that are manifested by um
by dynamic changes and
motor dysfunction and not non-motor
dysfunction
features
these are accompanied by
neuroinflammation uh impaired protein
clearance mechanisms and mitochondrial
dysfunction
now there are um
familial and
what we would call sporadic so those are
those are forms of parkinson's disease
where there's no known genetic component
so they're they're familiar and
non-familial forms of parkinson's
disease it has a prevalence of 100 to
200 in a hundred thousand
and so it's not actually considered a
rare disorder
um it has a average age and onset of
about 60 years affects men slightly more
and patients live typically for about 10
20 years after diagnosis
major contributors uh factors
contributing to mortality are falls
and pneumonia
and uh there are scientific rationale
for uh
the application of tlr-29
and 9 antagonists for the treatment of
parkinson's disease um here is just an
overview of findings in patients
indicating that
we're showing that tlr2 receptors and
tlr9 receptors are increased in parks
since
parkinson's
disease patients brains so these are
postmortem evaluations
and what they also know because they
have the the core of the accompanying uh
clinical data is that tlr2 expression
correlates with increased alpha nuclear
burden and disease duration in these
patients
oh
okay
we also have
evidence from animal studies and
basically confirming the roles of these
two receptors in a neurodegenerative
like process
um and so combinations of knockout
animals and or antisense uh inhibitory
applications
with existing
familial
and or toxin-induced models
shows us that you can
reduce
neurodegeneration by blocking these two
receptors in various animal models
for als again we have a protein
pathology component
and that's
leads to progressive degeneration of
corticospinal tracts and ultimately
muscle loss
which
is then uh
manifested as uh symptoms of where you
see progressive loss of muscle
innervation leading to
dysfunction of voluntary movement and
ultimately respiratory complications
leading to mortality
there is a strong inflammatory component
that's been noted in als
and there's a
a potentially clinically translatable
marker of tspo pet which
is a surrogate market for for
inflammation
for als that's been well characterized
for clinical subtypes again there are
genetic forms as well as sporadic forms
as well as different variations based on
the
limbs
the progression of whether or not it's a
arms versus legs how that progresses
um patients typically are younger at
onset
this disease is much more rapid
in terms of progression
males and females are are equally
affected
and
unlike parkinson's disease als is
considered a rare disorder with a
prevalence of five and a hundred
thousand
and again we have um
a whole host of uh scientific rationale
um for involvement of these two uh
receptors toll-like receptors two and
nine in this disease
and we have um
evidence from uh
our uh our own internal programs um
demonstrating that if we antagonize
these receptors in the in the mouse
model that we can improve multiple
endpoints
potentially relevant to the disease
and
then
finally guillain-barre syndrome this is
a little bit different in that
this is
a acute demyelinating polyneuropathy
and uh it's it's disease presentation is
a little bit different um to be honest
with you quite a few of these patients
recover but there is a substantial
number of those who don't
um this is considered a rare disorder
and uh it's not free it's not typically
um
it doesn't typically lead to death but
it does affect the patients and there
are some subsets of patients who
actually never fully recover from this
disorder
and again we have rationale for why we
think uh this approach the antagonism of
tlr2 and tlr9 receptors might work as a
therapeutic strategy for guillain-barre
syndrome
and i won't go through that all the way
but i will tell you that we have a
little bit of data
from evaluations of these dual
inhibitors in pre-clinical animal models
of parkinson's disease als and
guillain-barre syndrome
and
the res altogether these results
demonstrate that our this intervention
uh improved multiple disease relevant
outcomes in all three models
so in parkinson's disease and als models
there were reductions in protein
pathology inflammatory markers as well
as improved motor function in health
and in an outsourced study of rat of the
rat ean model of gumberry syndrome
we saw
improvements in health disease severity
scoring and a reduction in
improvement in myelination
so
now i'll share
for the last bit of my talk i'll share
the highlights of our findings today for
our findings in the parkinson's and als
models
that were enabled by our use of the
luminix platform
so first
these are data from a one month
evaluation of our early program molecule
npt 1220-312
and the take-home message here is that
treatment for one month with our
compound
improved a cytokine profile in a
transgenic mouse model of parkinson's
disease
so
with what you see here are
the smaller
circle that looks like it's on its side
the oval that's on its side is the
non-transgenic vehicle
the more upright uh circle on your left
that would be the
transgenic model that's just vehicle
treated
and then you see in
the
larger circle that's sort of on its side
that those animals have
what could be
to be interpreted as a normalized
profile
and so this is very interesting to us um
and you know we scratched our head a
little bit because uh
there's a lot to unpack here in terms of
you know a normal uh
cytokine profile in an animal model and
what we do to it with our treatment
but we're we're working on that
so
on the next slide
we have data from our first evaluation
of
a of the same compound
in a
transgenic mouse model of als
and uh
you know we administered an early
program molecule again the 312 compound
two mice the one transgenic mice for one
month
and so after we finished the in life
portion of the study one of our viva
scientists identified and evaluated uh
available study samples which
unfortunately were brain but not spinal
cord because we had allocated the spinal
cord entirely to um
uh neuropathology
evaluations um so we didn't have any for
biochemistry or this gene expression um
but this uh
one of our group uh took this brain
samples and used a quantagine multiplex
kit um on the luminex platform
and looked for uh
changes or differences in um
tlr specific
gene expression and tsp which i if you
recall that's uh the marker
a circuit marker for neuroinflammation
that's been evaluated in als
and so uh
on the left you see just the simple bar
graphs and as you can see the
differences um between the uh the
left two bars those are the uh
non-transgenic and transgenic control
groups they're not huge differences
but there were suggestions that we had
some differences between the
non-transgenic and the transgenic
as well as possibly some treatment
effects
so
if we looked at the profile of this gene
expression for this kit and you can see
what i'm i mean basically this this
this uh visualizes what i just described
to you which is that you've basically
got an overlay of all your groups and
you know here and there it looks like
you have hints of separation
possibly for treatment
so um
basically we decided that um you know
because it was such an easy evaluation
to run
that we would
allocate some sample in our next study
specifically for this purpose
and so i'll show you this now
so here uh these are data from the next
and most recent evaluation um study of a
newer compound of 1220-478
this is an als association
uh funded study
this was done again in the saad1 g93
transgenic mouse model of als
and so again in our uh portion of
reserve spinal cord um our researcher
evaluated
the samples across this platform using
this technology
and this time
we're in the spinal cord which is the
focus
of
most of the most severe pathology in als
this time we found very very robust
increases in uh
express expression of these various uh
tlr receptor subtypes and tspo
and uh moreover we also noted that we
had uh
what looked like treatment effects um in
these same samples
and if you look across it looks like the
most consistent effects are at the 10
migs per keg so um
we went ahead and decided to to look to
visualize that visualize that here um
and so what you show what shown here is
a radar plot of this
abnormal tlr
and tspo profile
and so in the center you've got the um
the dashed lines so that's your
your non-transgenic control
your the
outer bounded uh
billimeter here is the transgenic
vehicle controls and the intermediate
line
is the um
the 10 per kid treated group and so this
is a nice way to just to visualize where
the changes are
and
we're very happy with this
maybe not not the most straightforward
set of data
some people look at this and they say oh
my goodness well you know how but tlr7
2r7 has moved and you're a tlr2 and tlr9
antagonist how is it doing that well
it's um you know you're looking at the
sum of what's happened as a result of
your chronic administration so um
there's the possibility of compensatory
changes as well um and and also that
crosstalk between different uh
pathways so we're not bothered by that
at all
okay um
so finally i think i've got a few more
minutes in the last few slides i want to
share data from a translational
biomarker development effort that again
uses multiplex kits on the luminex
platform
and so we have been working on
developing and evaluating uh tlr agonist
evoked whole blood cytokine assay
experiments so this is a method where
you can obtain um in this case mouse or
human whole blood and we have
access to both both
in house for the mouse and for human
we've at this point in time mostly
purchased the blood from a blood bank
but you could imagine down the line um
we could do the same thing with
evoked models
for the mouse
you could take
normal healthy or patient blood and um
then
in vitro which is the next step you can
apply your intervention and your agonist
to see not only what the
evaluate not only your difference
between your groups of interest
but also a response profile which is
actually key
in my opinion and then
again using that on uh
employing the luminex platform so this
isn't something that we came up with on
our own necessarily this is a method
that's already been applied in phase one
and two studies um as measures of target
engagement and for proof of mechanism
biomarkers so that's something that
someone already has already successfully
done
um not for neurodegenerative diseases
but for another modality
um and in this case you know we're
really excited about this because we
think this could be important in terms
of a patient stratification biomarker so
remember
i mentioned that sometimes you have
non-responders
to your treatment
and those
you
those are part of your data analysis you
can't just make them go away
but
if you knew that there are
non-responders ahead of time you might
be able to
basically um
uh
use that as a inclusion exclusion
criteria so by by doing that you can
decrease your variability um that's
being contributed by that
and um so fit for purpose variations and
subject
treatment condition in vivo versus in
vitro treatment etc can be used to
address specific questions and so we
started to do this in the context of the
als program
but first let me just show you the the
the data from our method development
of
wild type and normal
healthies humans and so here i'm showing
you the tlr2 um
mouse whole blood cytokine assay data on
the top
and what we the important thing here is
that
in running these evaluations where you
first you run your agonist response
curves you find your of your effective
concentration
uh 50
and then you basically run your your
compound uh
dose response versus that in a separate
experiment
and so what we learned was that um this
method
translates really well and lines up with
what we had found
in terms of our in vivo and in vitro
potencies
so we're very very happy with that and
that really is helpful as you start to
project what your
therapeutic doses might be for the
clinic
so that's for tlr too
for tlr9 we also have developed and
validated that for mouse blood
and we've transferred both the tlr2 and
tlr9
assays for use with normal human blood
and
you know we like this one because the
multiplex evaluations give us
give us a very good handle on the
response profile across species and
within subject
so um
we decided uh for uh my final slide
almost final slide here my final data
slide i'm showing you data from
an evaluation where we
had a satellite group from an experiment
in the saad1 als model
so we treated these animals for one
month
with our compound
and at the end of the experiment the
study we took this group of animals and
at a pk defined end time point past
their last injection
we
uh
took sample took our sample
and then
we used that blood so this is an in vivo
treatment and then we use that blood
in vitro to conduct our agonist response
curves just to see um what those
response profiles looked
like between the groups and across the
analytes
and our so this first pass evaluation
actually i think was pretty interesting
um so
we have some example data here below
where you see um we have a
gcsf here on the left
and you know it looks like our
our control groups are pretty much laid
over each other
but you know we have some evidence that
our treatment intervention i mean that's
the
curve on the bottom
gives us some evidence that maybe this
particular ani analyte is a possible
treatment response of analyte
and the same thing for our il8
analyte
and then on the far right we have il-6
and in this case it looks like we have a
a possibly a starting difference
in levels with this analyte which is
something we'd actually seen by another
technology previously
and we see a different response profile
and that we think is really interesting
because it gives us
another way to differentiate
possibly to differentiate patients
because for instance in parkinson's
disease
we know
that not only are basal levels different
but the
the function of the of the
the integrity of the
inflammatory response or the immune
response is actually changed so in this
case that that really lines up with what
we see here
and so
we have more to do here with respect to
als and we're also planning to extend
these evaluations to our parkinson's
evaluation related evaluations
so my last 30 seconds um in summary um
the discovery development of cns disease
modifying therapeutics for
neurodegenerative diseases is a
difficult process that will prove as the
complexities of the disease are
elucidated so that's we need to learn
more about the patient and the disease
the development of biomarkers is a key
part of that process and
um you know i and many other people most
of the people in the field believe that
has to be done early um
and you know i hope that i've given you
some
indication and
uh
data showing you how we've been able to
use the luminex platform as a key
technology
um for our this process
and for our early translational
biomarker development efforts
thank you so much
all right thank you so much dr price for
your informative presentation we will
now start the q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen
now let's get started
our first question
and
so you show tlr gene expression data
what about biochemical evaluations
thank you for that question i
we are very interested in doing the
biochemical evaluations and you know i
mentioned that um
companies like luminex and millipore and
thermo
thermofisher
scientific those are all what we
consider industry partners
in that we contact people we say this is
what we're interested in doing how do we
how do we build a kit for this and
they don't get paid they help us out
they've been helping us out so we are
building um
assays for evaluation
of biochemical evaluations our only
limitations are basically just
what reagents are
available to help us with that
great thank you
another question we have
don't we already know which plasma
cytokines are different in parkinson's
disease patients
we know part of that
so
when i've mentioned the term unbiased i
mean part of
the issue is that
as a field we've been limited by our
technology and our reagents and so
researchers use what they can what they
what they have available to them and so
previously um you know kind of the best
that we could do on many levels was just
singleplex evaluations
and they often weren't
they were more qualitative than
quantitative
so now
with
you know the emergence of technologies
like
you know the multiplex kits and and
luminex and and other available um
technologies in the field
um we can kind of broaden our approach
now and i think that's actually really
helpful it's like um trying to decide
how a room looks by looking through the
keyhole
you don't really know what it looks like
until you open the whole door and that's
really what we're doing here by using
these technologies is opening the door
so we have a better view of what's
inside
thank you for that response
um another question i noticed that you
didn't mention the role of animal models
and translational failures what part do
they play
thank you for that question that's a
great question and a totally different
talk but i will say um as a person who's
used animal models throughout my career
i mean i
have over the last um 30 years
you know watched as animal models have
taken the brunt of the blame for
translational failures
and you know and there's a fair amount
to be blamed to be had with
how
we as researchers have used those models
um you know over interpretations
inappropriate
applications but ultimately
without that information about
the patients that i talked about
it's really hard to know how well your
animal how good your animal model is
and in the end it really matters um
what your questions are specific to your
therapeutic intervention and what your
target is so it yeah it's it's
complicated but um you know that's a
good question um you know there's blade
to be had there but ultimately
uh without that other information you
can't you can't
properly apply and use animal models
thank you
thank you for that
another question we have from the
audience
what are some of the immune responses
produced from the tlr2 and 9 antigenous
and do these antigenists recognize the
multitude of immune responses necessary
to contribute to your research goals
uh that's a good question
so
yeah so in in this case what we've done
um
like this is a little bit of a complex
question but for each of our
agonist provoked models
the way we validate it is um
with available tool compounds not our
own
to to basically look across that profile
and say
of the 32 analytes which of those
could we measure because sometimes you
have some that are consistently with
below the limit of detection
and um
of those which of those are sensitive to
the
inhibition using the best tool that we
have to block them
and so it's not perfect but again this
tells you how important it is to look at
an entire profile
so you know that allows us to see how
which analytes are sensitive and by
sensitive i mean they have to be
um you have to have a pretty good uh
response to the antagonism in terms of
your blockade so you know
over 50 percent
and there's overlap so it's complicated
that's a good question thank you
thank you we have some great questions
coming in
another one what is the relative
importance of neurobiomarkers versus
system systemic biomarkers example
inflammation related that's a great
question um and and this is another one
of those it's complicated answers um
so ideally we would have a way to
directly measure inflammation in the
brain
in our mouth studies a lot of what we do
uh postmortem is um basically what i
would call like snapshot evaluations of
inflammatory markers in the brain
either by using immunohistochemistry or
biochemical techniques that we just
can't do with patients it turns out so
we're really limited there in making
that
jump
but um there there are
we do know that in some way you
what you see in the periphery
is often a reflection of what you see
centrally
and so that is actually a very very
important part of the process for us um
and one that we're working through as
best as we can um you know i primarily
work with mice and so you know bridging
from the periphery to the brain it might
be nice to be able to do a csf
evaluation
it's really hard to find in vivo
pharmacologists who can do a very very
good
csf draw on a mouse it's really hard so
we're doing the best we can and we have
some ideas of how we might actually
answer that a different way but that's a
really good question
great
the next question we have do you see
changes in the same cytokines across
different neurodegenerative disease
models
that's a great question uh thank you
carrie um
that
sometimes we do
sometimes we don't and uh
it also depends on i i
briefly mentioned a
treatment intervention point for
patients and that actually
complicates our use of the animal models
quite a bit because
there's there's a lot that goes into
deciding how old the animals need to be
at what point in their lifespan do you
use them in terms of you know do you
have a developed pathology that's
accompanied by symptoms
so uh
let's see uh
i lost that question
i'm sorry um that's okay i mean
yeah so so that changes so it depends on
what time what point of the animal
progression for each
line
which animal model
so yes sometimes there's overlap just
it's not always
easy to interpret
all right um another question we have
what made you decide to use the luminex
platform versus other available
platforms
uh good question um
i had a very talented biochemist
in the avivo group
who
noticed the platform and made a really
compelling case to me and the management
this is why you need it because it's a
you know we were struggling using the
mice in terms of you have sample
from brain or plasma
and if you're going to run a western
blot it takes a huge amount of sample
and
then you're done you basically
that's it that's the last that's the
last evaluation that you'll have
and so
you know she made the case that
you know given uh the amount that the
system costs and the kits
it would allow us to be very very
flexible
it we had to we wouldn't have to use
very much sample
and so
you know in the end it was i mean she
did a very good job selling it and
that's basically why uh we decided to
invest in the platform and then we um
we commenced our in vitro counterparts
that it was also a good buy so
all right we have time for just a couple
more questions
um and the next one we have here aren't
multiplex studies really just fishing
expeditions
uh that's a good question um yes
in one way they are um
you know
there are a lot of endpoints for
clinical evaluations that um
you know really just haven't planned
panned out and um so part of what the
field's doing in general is taking a
step back and saying hey
you know maybe we need to think outside
the box a little bit here
and so
i think it follows that if if there's
comfort in the clinical space in doing
that in early clinical trials that
pre-clinically in animal models we
should be
kind of following suit because
we don't always know what's going to be
important
and so you know it's funny thinking
about
genetic you know the genome evaluations
people have gotten very very comfortable
in evaluating tens of thousands of genes
um
and essentially that would be a phishing
expression but uh but um yeah we just i
think there's just a level of comfort um
now that the technologies have advanced
to enable that type of evaluations um
there's just you know there's a time for
the rest of the field to catch up and
become comfortable with the types of
analyses that go with that and and using
it in a way
that's proper so
yeah great thank you dr price i think we
are going to wrap with that final
question um do you have any final
comments for our audience
um
not too much thank you for for coming
today and i'd be happy if anybody uh
wants to
ask me something that occurs to you
later offline just just email me and i'd
be happy to respond to you
great thank you again dr price for your
time today and your important research
before we go i'd like to thank thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions i'd also
like to thank our sponsor luminex adia
soaring company for sponsoring today's
webinar
and like dr price said questions we do
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until march 10 2024 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for the replay we encourage
you to share that email with any of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you